Democrats are ready to go off the deep
end on impeachment despite no bombshell
evidence and a total lack of public
support almost half House Democrats want
to open impeachment inquiry against the
president House Judiciary Chairman Jerry
Nadler is one of the Democrats leading
the charge my personal view is that he
richly deserves impeachment he has done
many impeachable offenses he's violated
the law six ways from Sunday but that's
not the question the question is can we
develop enough evidence to put before
the American people while Democrats
can't come to grips with the fact that
Robert Muller's testimony was a total
flop according to a new poll nearly half
of Americans say the hearings didn't
move the needle to change their views on
impeachment all right yeah so that's no
surprise everybody was pretty locked in
but one what Jerry Nadler said
interested me he's basically saying
after two years and millions of dollars
with 17 lawyers they still haven't
developed enough evidence that he
committed high crimes and misdemeanors
don't you think we would have known by
now I think he said that he believes
that there is justification for
impeachment but he wants the American
people to see it in a way that's
convincing because this is a political
act this is not about a court of law
Jesse right so but they're still not
well he wants to build the case in terms
of public perception so that he can have
it because by the way you were wrong
it's like in terms of public pressure
it's like 65 to 70 percent of Democrats
think the president should be impeached
but if you go to the broader audience
especially Republicans they don't think
it and independence also don't seem to
think right but this should be the the
poll we were citing was that no one's
opinions changed well a lot of people
didn't change but I think even in the
recent Fox poll what you see is a slight
hiccup in the number of people who say
he should be impeached my thought is
Nancy Pelosi is the whole ball game most
important player and she is unchanged as
she falls into your category there and
she doesn't see impeachment as done as
advancing democratic policies or
democratic politics the politics I think
from Nancy Pelosi's view is that really
you know what beat him at election time
and don't allow him to posture as the
great martyr for people on his side oh
these Democrats
oh the press they're after me you know
what just beat him at the polls I mean
people want to fire him today for what's
going on with the intelligence community
and getting dan coates out there and
putting the political hacking I think
Brennan was the hacked what do you think
about Pelosi now has I guess attempted
to quiet the impeachment push is she
successful because I thought it'd be
dead after the Muller hearings I got
really quiet of it though they're still
doing the pseudo impeachment without
really doing impeachment right so
they're claiming this is all about
oversight with Jerry Nadler going on and
saying that his personal view that he
should be impeached and accusing the
president of all these crimes and if
we're not going to see any change in
people's opinions after Moeller
testified which was supposed to be the
big ending I mean the report was
supposed to be the end that wasn't
satisfying enough then they bring him in
to testify that was a complete disaster
train wreck even Democrats are admitting
that and now she's trying again to
balance out the 70% of the Democrats who
want and Pietschmann with the moderates
who were voted in in 2018 that she would
like to win again in 2020 do you think
that Jerry Nadler is doing this because
he is facing a left-wing primary and
next year he's trying to go hard left to
snuff that out did that is that a
conspiracy theory or is that real I
don't think that Jerry now there's
probably that worry no no I mean a OSI
was able to Knockouts true a congressman
and remember he just sent a surrogate to
the debate because he didn't even care
maybe now they will pay more attention
Nancy Pelosi on the other hand though so
she's basically said August is going to
be the month that they win the messaging
and she said we're gonna focus it
exclusively on health care oh so we'll
see how that goes one thing she does
have in her favor is despite all of
these pressures the freshman Democrats
that won in those purple districts of
swing districts have raised a ton of
money they're way ahead of their
Republican counterparts so really is
that ya know immediately forgotten that
pretend like she did not say it I am
again this is their response after the
Muller Fiasco could you imagine if it
had been a success it would have been
like the red wedding a game of Thrones
bodies everywhere look you know what
impeachment is I keep thinking this is
to one's point I don't think this is
something that they really want if they
get it they're not gonna want it to ever
be like run away from home run away from
home and you make it what one block and
then you sit on the curb kind of miss
your parents and the meatloaf and you
turn around you come back did I think
that Democrats just want to say they're
running away from home they really don't
want to run away from home right so you
don't really believe that they want to
impeach the president I think there's
some that do but I think overall they
did to Juan's point I think they know
that we'll turn him into a martyr it
will help him the way it helped Bill
Clinton but they over leveraged
themselves it would be better for them
all if they would just recognize that
the 2016 election really was about
policy right and about approach and
about tone and not about this because
I've been chasing this for so long and
the longer that they wait the closer
that we get to 2020 all right we're
getting pretty close